un climat de peur s'est installée dans
la ville de juarez aux portes des états
unis deux gangs rivaux se livrent un
combat d'une violence sans précédent
tout a commencé par un affrontement dans
cette prison des familles sous le choc
sont sans nouvelles des détenus
on est chanceux d'être parti en vie de
la mère de prisonniers à l'intérieur des
enfants pleuraient des personnes âgées
mouret ils ont lancé des bombes des
cocktails molotov tout brûler les
attaques se déplace dans la ville les
cartels incendies des véhicules ouvrent
le feu sur des magasins et tire sans
pitié sur des innocents dans ce
restaurant de pizza quatre employés
d'une station de radio ont été tués
ce n'était pas arrivé avant et on espère
que cela ne se reproduise plus des
personnes innocentes ont été attaqués en
représailles se désole le président du
m'expliquer
la garde nationale et déployé sur le
terrain 600 militaires arrivent pour
renforcer la sécurité dans la ville les
autorités ont mis la main sur six
membres présumés du gang le calme et
chic laisse le chapeau sur le groupe
rival a des liens avec le cartel de
l'ancien baron de la drogue el chapo
emprisonné aux états unis
nous n'arrêterons page qu'est ce que
l'ordre soit rétabli et nous utiliserons
toutes les ressources nécessaires pour y
parvenir averti roberto fierro procureur
de l'état de chihuahua la vague de
violences a fait onze victimes à roue à
risques majoritairement des civils plus
à l'ouest la guerre de la drogue au
mexique terrorise ou si les résidents de
tijuana mexique ali et rosary tôt près
de la frontière américaine et c'est
charles du boullay rade canada montréal